sony vient d'officialiser son nouveau
xperia mark iv alors à dire pas je me
plains de sony de partout là c'est la
foire aux s'animer parce que j'utilise
sony pour filmer d'ailleurs c'est une
caméra de sony l'a donc j'aime bien la
marque je la préfère au niveau photo que
smartphone différentes raisons parce
qu'ils sont excellents même si en
smartphones je dois reconnaître quelque
chose qu'ils ont quand même plutôt pas
mal on va regarder ça on va essayer de
comprendre pour refaire un historique
très court par rapport aux marchés c'est
très très différent et je me suis
souvent dit ça va pas être la bonne
solution pour monsieur et madame tout le
monde qui veut acheter un smartphone et
à force de voir toujours des nouveaux
smartphones arrivée qui se ressemblait
énormément j'ai fini par me dire ah
c'est pas mal quand même ce qu'ils font
parce que c'est pour le coup un peu
différent et sa propre aux autres et
continue là dedans clairement donc on se
fait un tour du sony xperia 5 mark iv
c'est dans la gamme vous avez l'xperia
un ex-paria one qui est le plus haut de
gamme vous avez ex-paria 10 qui va être
le plus au milieu de gamme vous avez
celui là qui est du haut de gamme mais
qu'il en a pas autant sous le capot que
l'xperia 1 et puis m marcade parce que
c'est la quatrième édition alors ils
font comment photos qu'on fait ça comme
ça donc on va regarder aujourd'hui ce
qu'il a sous le ventre on va regarder
s'il est intéressant je vous lis tout de
suite c'est un prototype que j'ai donc
on n'est pas sur la version définitive
il se peut que quelques petites choses
qui changent non pas au niveau de la
fiche technique n'ont pas non plus à
l'intérieur mais au niveau de la
fabrication entre le modèle que j'ai moi
et le modèle que vous auriez vous si
vous en achetez un et d'ailleurs s'il
vous intéresse coup mais les liens
justement dans la description allez on y
va c'est près on et gaumont tintin
[Musique]
alors regardez en termes de design or
est dense que sony sait faire dans ce
que sony aime faire c'est à dire un
smartphone assez long avec une super
prise en main l'intérêt est
effectivement d'être très long comme ça
c'est qu'on a un écran 21 9ème et ce que
nous dit sony sait que c'est le ratio
cinémascope pour avoir vraiment une
expérience cinéma sur leur smartphone
c'est l'idée une fois de plus sony ils
veulent allier tous les noms qu'il
maîtrise des fois c'est bien et des fois
c'est un peu moins bien à savoir un
écran bravia oled avec la meilleure
qualité que vous pourrez retrouver
effectivement ici l'expérience audio qui
sont très forts également dans tout le
duo notamment au niveau des différents
casque ça on en a déjà parlé on en
parlera à utah rayonnement également
expérience au niveau de la photo
expérience au niveau de la vidéo
expérience du côté du gaming avec
playstation donc c'est vraiment toute
cette idée qu'on va avoir ici dans ce
smartphone est dedans et smartphones de
sony et si c'est une diagonale de 6,1
pouces et c'est un écran oled donc on a
un écran qui est je trouve une fois de
plus bien fait bien calibré et plus
lumineux que ce qu'on avait sur la
génération précédente à tourner sur un
android 12 ici avec trois ans de mise à
jour de sécurité je sais un petit peu
trop terne par rapport à ce qu'on peut
retrouver aujourd'hui chez notre
concurrent voyez parce qu'il n'ya pas
des limitations n'y a pas de séparation
c'est ton sur ton face je trouve ça un
peu tristounet très honnêtement et il
aurait pu faire un peu mieux et
cherchait vraiment à améliorer sa nm
comptable dans les sous menus c'est
tellement austère c'en est vraiment
dommage du coup il ya rien qui vous
saute à l'oeil il faut vraiment venir
chercher alors tendez nous on veut aller
dans écran et y avait dans les réglages
de la qualité de l'image alors moi je me
suis mis en mode créateurs qui va avoir
des côtes un peu plus violine légèrement
plus violine cette partie là que le mode
standard qui est plus bleuté plus ternes
je trouve donc je préfère ce petit mode
créateurs vous avez une fonction hdr en
temps réel à vous de voir ce que
voulaient venir lancer également chou ça
pas mal après vous pouvez vous mettre
comme ça en mode stand à avec le mode de
créateurs qui va se lancer
automatiquement en fonction des applis
cia les applications qui vont être
compatibles mais moi je préfère le mode
créateur par défaut qui me plaira
davantage autres choses à connaître
c'est le taux de rafraîchissement alors
vous avez un taux de rafraîchissement de
120 hertz mais
alors si on écoute bien je lui aurais
demandé merci beaucoup au revoir à
demain tu es syrie on a un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz qui n'est
pas adaptative c'est à dire que vous
êtes soit en s'envoyant tout le temps
soit en 60 hertz tout le temps et je
trouve ça un peu dommage qu'on n'ait pas
d'adaptateur ici sur ce smartphone là et
je vous lis tout de suite moment je
tourne la vidéo j'ai pas le tarif le
smartphone lui il ya quelques jours sale
affaire depuis quatre cinq jours que je
lai sony n'a pas encore annoncé les
tarifs joue le match juste en bas dans
les dix comme ça vous aurez le tarif il
faut savoir que le mark iii était sorti
l'année dernière il est à plus de 1000
euros c'était très très cher je ne sais
pas ce qu'ils vont voir fait sur celui
là mais par rapport au positionnement il
faut quand même qu'il soit beaucoup
moins cher donc on verra ça sera là je
voyage surprise d'autant plus son
smartphone fils était je vous dis bien
mille euros aux alentours de 1000 euros
sans taux de rafraîchissement adaptatif
j'aurai un peu de mal à comprendre pour
continuer avec le design moi j'aime bien
alors c'est du sony 1 c'est très
différent et je trouve très intéressant
qu'on a un truc différent votre module
photo sur le côté qui est très standard
mais une fois de plus c'est une
signature sony pour trouver votre bouton
avec le volume juste là le capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui déverrouille
très rapidement et qui marche bien puis
vous avez un petit bouton ici pour nous
faire prendre des photos comme on est
chez sony et qui veulent être dans
l'univers photo je prends mon truc voyez
je mets comme ça attaque j'appuie ça
prend une photo et la photo vous l'avez
là vous voyez quoi vous voyez un boîtier
sony merci sony et bravo donc ça c'est
assez rigolo de ce côté là de l'autre
côté vous n'avez absolument rien sur le
dessous vous retrouvez votre tiroir de
cartes sim alors il n'y a pas de petites
piques pour bien l'ouvrir vous le prenez
vous l'ouvrez et vous l'avez directement
comme sur ce curieux pas mal non plus
carte sim là et sd de l'autre côté comme
ça vous êtes peinard et vous pouvez
venir augmenter le stockage à noter vous
le voyez si vous avez une prise jack
pour une excellente expérience audio on
est en maille rays ici on est également
en high res voyant l'est wireless sans
fil donc si vous avez des écouteurs sans
fil sony ou autre eh bien vous pourrez
avoir une expérience sans fil voilà le
principe le smartphone est plutôt bien
fichu biens fabriqués très réactif il
fonctionne bien vous avez ici un des
derniers pour ses centrales comme celle
de snapdragon 8 jane 1 alors qu'on va
venir reprocher à ce processeur c'est
qu'il va chauffer un petit peu trop
alors une fois de plus si je vous le dis
moi j'ai vraiment un prototype et mon
poto tee shirt il chauffe beaucoup donc
j'ai vachement de chaleur voyez une
petite chaleur ici et quand je joue ça
choque davantage alors de toute façon la
chaleur on l'aura parce que ce
processeur il vient chauffer y a pas de
magie mais je suis pas sûr qu'ils
chauffent autant que ce que je peux
avoir moi ça vient à mon avis du proton
a confirmé sur des tests ultérieurement
pour pouvoir trouver chez tous mes
copains de la presse tout en sachant et
je vous le dis quand même qu'ici vous
avez un corps nu gauriaguet ce virus
donc c'est un smartphone qui résistants
alors moi je les balader et les
smartphones les balades en conditions
réelles d'un cerf je devrais faire plus
grave je sais se balade dans ma poche
avec un smartphone avec deux smartphones
à l'e3 smartphone ça fait très grandes
poches comme ça on va vraiment si les
résistants et j'ai pas noté de marque
particulière je le trouve plutôt bien
faits y compris à l'arrière envoyé ce qu
il a frotté s'est fait une petite balade
tout à l'heure dans ma poche avec un
autre smartphone et ça bouge pas donc
bon plutôt correct à lorient n'a
toutefois que ma vraie plus pour le coup
je vous monte c'est sur youtube c'est
que je trouve que on a de l'audio de
qualité avec les haut parleurs c'est
plutôt rare donc il faut venir le
souligner ici vous avez alors il n'y a
pas une vraie symétrie entre les deux
haut parleurs parce que ce ne sont pas
les mêmes hauts parleurs mais regardez
premier haut parleurs qui fut manqué
juste ici là et non pas sur le côté or
en termes de directivité on est pas mal
ça nous arrive en face et le deuxième il
est là là on va vraiment dans la même
directivité entre droite et gauche à
gauche lo par l'offre un peu plus petit
donc ça sera très différente sera pas
complètement précis mais déjà le fait
d'avoir cette même directivité c'est
beaucoup plus immersif est fausse a
vraiment pas mal alors là je l' ai mis à
fond on n'est pas obligé de le faire
rigoler mais je trouve que le son est
clair le son match bien qu'ils avaient
un spike qui est là je crois pas non
plus faire des questions resteraient
smartphones mais ça c'est bien
franchement moi j'ai beaucoup de plaisir
à venir écouter des films des séries
comme ça à venir jouer à des jeux je
trouve que c'est immersif et ça marche
bien et je vous le dis une fois de plus
il ya très peu de smartphones où c'est
le cas donc ça il faut vraiment le
souligner et dire que sony a fait du
beau boulot là dessus je trouve aussi
que le job est plutôt bien fait aussi au
niveau de l'eau de façon globale on a du
dolby atmos bien évidemment ailleret
audio je voulais dit on à du lda qu'ont
également le ds l'ultimate ça ça va être
un 9 skylink qui va augmenter qui va
améliorer la qualité audio si jamais
votre source est pas parfaite un drap
l'améliorer bon sait jamais que du
logiciel est surtout là ici il est prêt
pour le bluetooth est le et ça c'est
bien et une où l'on dit sony maison mais
une nouvelle structure au niveau des
hauts parleurs et je trouve que pour le
coup ils ont bien bossé alors après il
ya plein de petites choses ou bien les
logiciels chez sony des fois c'est bien
des fois un peu moins bien là c'est bien
musique pro pouvait venir enregistrer
différents projets si vous par exemple
vous décidé de parler de chanter pour
les mettre à cette distance là je chante
je ne chante pas mais je pourrais
chanter si vous voulez faire de la
guitare vous le baisser un petit peu
pour certaines capté à la fois les
guetta et votre voix et après vous venez
module est plus de voix vous rapprocher
plus de guitares vos modules et mal à
vous bougez vous bougez à 10 ans pas
trop loin parce que vous risquez de
récupérer trop le bruit de pièces mais
pas trop proche non plus sinon vous
allez dire coucher le micro ça va
saturer sera pas terrible donc cette
petite fonctionnalité je trouve pas mal
une fois de plus sony s'adresse aux
créateurs aux créatifs là si vous êtes
musicien vrai ikos et vous voulez
maquetter sur votre smartphone à juni d
allonnes là haut up afin tube on
l'enregistré il sort à la radio ou pas
ou sur spotify vous voulez peut-être il
sortira jamais en tout cas celui sortira
jamais c'est une certitude donc ça c'est
plutôt bien plus que d'un côté
applicatif alors il me faut toujours des
choses très bizarres ça reste sony chose
qui est bien qui datent pas
d'aujourd'hui mais il ya quelques temps
et bien ils ont uni et les applications
photo une fois de plus sony s'adresse
aux créateurs aux créatifs patent et au
commun des mortels on peut si vous êtes
le commun des mortels mais je trouve que
des fois ce smartphone il vaut mieux
l'avoir si vous connaissez déjà un petit
peu l'univers sony donc ça c'est le mode
basic moi je fais du foot et toutes mes
photos en mode basic parce qu'après vous
avez d'autres modes vous avez un mode
automatique hockey le programme
automatique l'obturateur un mode manuel
enfin bref il ya pas mal de différentes
possibilités pour retrouver un peu
l'univers des boîtiers sony alpha pour
ma part je considère que je teste ce
smartphone comme si quelqu'un ne
connaissais pas grand-chose ne veut pas
s'embêter comme si je prenais des
smartphones et je voulais pas mettre le
mode professionnel dont je vous ai tous
shooter comme ça à leur premier truc que
j'aime pas des masses c'est que lorsque
je viens shooter comme ça voyez je suis
une photo voisins et lorsque je veux
remonter et ben je trouve ça encore le
foie 07 il y là il est facile mais si je
veux aller sur un truc un peu plus au
bain il faut vraiment que je le monte là
je peux appuyer là mais enfin c'est
graduelle et pour autant la voyez si
vous retournez tout de suite sur le x 1
et bas ségala faut vraiment au jour
descendre et je n'ai pas directement où
je trouve qu'il ya un truc qui est un
poids lourd au louvre et les petits
raccourcis ou alors pour autant c'est
très intuitif si je veux y aller
progressivement et je suis sur la photo
donc ça ne m'intéresse pas et voilà ça
je trouve que c'est pas complètement
dingue alors pour autant une fois de
plus et sony nous rajoute plein de
petites choses voyez vous avez plein de
petites options pour venir régler votre
bouquet ici gnagnagna bref bon il ya
plein d'options on est une fois de plus
chez sony et dans l'idée pourquoi pas
c'est différent mais une fois de plus je
pense vraiment qu'ils viennent chercher
et qui veulent s'adresser à des
personnes connaissent la marque qui aime
et qui veulent retrouver une extension
un peu leur boîtier alors on a un truc
qui est très bien chez sony c'est la
reconnaissance du visage ymca me
reconnaît avec l'eye tracking ils
traquent mon oeil donc là vous le voyez
il ya vraiment le petit truc sur l'oeil
et reconnaissance de ma tronche donc ça
ça marche vachement bien on le voit à
l'arrière on a un triple module photo
toujours en partenariat d'exane on va
avoir un triple capteur de 12 mégapixels
que ce soit sur votre ultra-grand-angle
en 16 mm sur votre grand angle 24 mm ou
vote et l'objectif sur un 60 mm et non
pas 50 mm ça c'est plutôt marrant parce
que avant on retrouvait plutôt un 50 mm
laisse en fait le choix de mettre en 60
pour venir chercher un peu plus
directement donc le outre un peu plus
prononcée et dans l'idée bon l'idée
l'idée pas mal et je vous montre le
résultat dans quelques instants tout en
sachant qu'on peut bien faire de la
vidéo ici également sur les 3 capteurs
en 120 images par seconde donc si vous
êtes créatif et que vous voulez utiliser
le 60 mm le 16 12 24 ans 60 images par
secondes ça marchera à l'avant on a
aussi une caméra de cette fille ici
essayez du 12 mégapixels alors qu'avant
on atteint 8 mégapixels moyens petits
tabourets dit on peut bien filmé
également ici jusqu'au 4 cas à 120
images par seconde et je vous disais
quel que soit l'objectif que vous allez
choisir vous avez une stabilisation
optique sur le 24 et sur le 60 mm plutôt
bien également sur 60 ça vous évite de
venir bouger surtout moi ça vient un peu
stabilisé l'histoire est là où je trouve
que sony est un petit peu trop complexe
et que autant pour la photo vous avez
une application ils ont tous réunis ça
c'est bien autant pour la vidéo vous
avez trois possibilités la première vous
allez passer par l'application un peu
standard et vous venez switcher
directement ici en mode vidéo donc là
pouvaient venir filmer très très
facilement ok ça me va ensuite j'ai une
application vidéo pro donc là on
s'adresse pour des personnes qui s'y
connaissent davantage vous choisissez
l'objectif 24 mm autofocus manuelle ou
automatique vous voulez régler ici on va
se mettre en automatique et c'est votre
objectif donc là vous ou mais vous des
zones et vous avez un menu également au
niveau du réglage de bosis votre balance
des blancs et compagnie ont déjà
franchement faut commencer à bien y
connaître et puis ensuite vous avez
toutes les informations ici balance des
blancs automatique votre isolé soit 125
l'obturateur je suis un centième votre
niveau également et puis tant
l'enregistrement et le niveau 1 du micro
qui en 1920 par 1080 p je suis en 30
images par secondes suivant sdr ok donc
ça il ya cette application là pour faire
filmer mais ça ne s'arrête pas là parce
que sony zem bien complexifier beaucoup
les choses vous avez également
l'application cinéma pro qui est juste
là et lorsque vous arrivez là cinéma pro
on l'a déjà vu également avancé c'est
votre résolution le nombre d'image dans
le projet et vous avez un look en fait
ça va venir 21 c'est une teinte de votre
votre image votre objectif balance des
blancs mise au point fps l'iso bref
l'obturateur et puis en bas vous êtes
plein de petites images le niveau la
mémoire la batterie le codec enfin bon
il ya plein de choses qui sont un peu en
doublon pour moi il devrait chercher à
tous que claire simple unifiée plutôt
que mettre le bazar une fois de plus
pour le consommateur alors bon a le truc
qui est cool c'est que si vous voulez
vraiment faire de la vidéo que si votre
dallas là le soir vous pouvez choisir
banon se tapissent j'aime pas je prends
de celle là et en plus c'est d'appeler
native sony donc elle est totalement
optimisé mais à côté de ça je trouve que
pour le commun des mortels ça ça fout le
bordel mais d'une façon énorme donc
voilà ils se disent boychuk qui peut le
plus peut le moins moi je pense que qui
peut le plus ça sert à rien voilà une
fois de plus ça reste mon poignet on
commence par la photo ni bisman quelques
photos moi je les trouvais alors je
pense qu'en fait une autre mise à jour
qui va arriver donc j'étais pas la
version définitive une peu plus c'est un
proto sk des mises à jours qui vont
venir corriger ça parce que
bizarre mais c'est pas bien enfin de ce
que j'ai là moi en tout cas c'est pas
bon je vous montre un différentes photos
de nuit se trouve que la gestion de la
lumière est pas bonne l'image est plate
il n'y a pas de contraste c'est pas joli
même quand il ya du mouvement voyez
c'est fou non ça marche pas gardez là
c'est pareil une photo de nature c'est
pas beau c'est plat non on a regardé la
peut-être que la main à bouger mais bon
non alors j'ai fait différents petits
trucs tests avec des pokémon lorsqu'on a
de la lumière bon très honnêtement ça
vient peut-être de la version logicielle
que j'ai j'ai fait la mise à jour avant
de venir shoot et compagnie je pense
qu'on aura d'autres parce qu'une fois de
plus c'est une phase de test avant que
le produit soit lancé donc bon je vous
invite quand même à venir voir les tests
des médias a posteriori fois le
lancement passé j'espère qu'il y en aura
parce que de ce que je vois là je suis
loin d'être convaincu et une fois de
plus des soutes et en mode basique à un
mode automatique ce sont les objectifs
en venant me rapprocher sur le grand
angle ultra grand-angle alors il aime
bien sony garder cette passe vraiment en
photos naturelles où on vient faire ses
propres réglages et c'est pour ça que
vous avez tous très sombre ici alors
qu'un autre smartphone vous l'aurez
éclaircir mais bon voilà c'est c'est
vraiment le choix de sony mais je trouve
que oui entre grand temps les ultra
grand-angle on a pas du tout de
cohérence au niveau de la teinte je suis
vraiment loin d'être convaincu on peut
faire des trucs mais là vous avez une
belle eau turquoise on la voit un peu
mais voilà je ne suis pas je suis pas
transcendé un jeu monte rapidement mais
on peut faire des choses la caméra de
celle fille c'est pareil on a augmenté
la qualité mais bon ça ne transcende pas
donc je reste un peu sur ma faim au
niveau de toute la partie photo et je
trouve que vu l'endroit où je vous en ai
vu les paysages qui sont magnifiques
salles et sublime pas et ça ça me
frustre vachement regarder la naine la
voyez là au niveau des hautes lumières
c'est pas dingue alors c'est sur l'ultra
grand temps mais bon normalement ça
devrait quand même être pas trop mauvais
il a il a du mal hein donc là j'ai
continué de plomb dans paris bon voilà
on peut faire des choses mais bon je
pense qu'il faut vraiment une mise à
jour qui va sublimer sa là les hautes
lumières s'évader les autres films bien
là la variole soleil effectivement mais
à d'autres smartphones qui sortiront
beaucoup mieux et du coup voilà ça me
perturbe un peu et une fois de plus bon
on peut faire des trucs mais voilà je
suis pas hyper hyper emballé donc là on
va avoir un suivi suivi de là et c'est
une grosse techno cas sony et qu'elle
réplique ici dans ses smartphones alors
qu'elle les a dans ces boîtiers qui
marche très bien c'est à dire savoir
dire reconnaître votre oeil et ça va
vous suivre donc ici pas de flou de la
netteté tout le temps vous soyez ce soit
pour suivre un humain ou poursuivre un
autre et voyez pour un objet ça suit on
voit bien le petit carré dessus on voit
bien la netteté qui va faire partout où
je vais mettre ma bouteille mais moi je
m'en mets vraiment sur le côté et tout
le reste est flou donc là ça ne le perds
pas ça me le suis donc striking là je
trouve vachement bien alors c'est un
smartphone qui bénéficie d'un avis ride
au niveau de la batterie pompage d'une
batterie de 4500 milliards eur et une
batterie de 5000 milliampères cette
année donc ça c'est quand même plutôt
bien ici sony nous annonce trois ans de
vie au niveau de sa batterie donc bon ok
avec une charge rapide 30 watts est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut continuer à dire
que 30 watts et de la charge rapide je
suis pas extrêmement convaincu vous
rechargez à 50 % en 30 minutes tout en
sachant que le bloc de charges n'est pas
fourni dans la boîte est d'ailleurs le
câble nous et qui si vous n'avez pas de
recharge sans fil il a une certification
ip65 et ip68 donc résistant à l'eau et à
la poussière ça c'est bien et si vous
souhaitez ajouter une deuxième carte sim
parce que je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure vous avez une seule carte sim
vous pouvez avoir une vie sinon bon ce
smartphone est ce qu'il faut venir
l'acheter ça dépend ça dépend vraiment
de vous parce que si vous êtes amoureux
de sony si vous aimez la marque si vous
avez déjà eu l'expérience sony au niveau
d'un smartphone pourquoi pas moi je peux
pas vous donner aujourd'hui un retour
ferme et définitif par rapport à la
photo parce que je le trouve un peu
moyen mais ce qui est sûr et connaissant
l'univers de sony et ce qu'ils aiment
faire sony screen certitude c'est que de
toute façon si vous voulez un smartphone
un peu politique tout automatique où
vous prenez une photo et vous avez un
algorithme qui va bosser derrière pour
vous embellir et vous sortir la
meilleure photo que c'est pas là dessus
qu'il faut aller si vous voulez venir
acheter ce smartphone c'est que vous
aimez venir gratter vos paramètres si
vous voulez gérer vous même votre propre
photo parce que même si un mode
automatique et même si la photo sera
optimisée et améliorée grâce à
différentes mises à jours j'imagine en
tout cas j'ose l'espérer parce qu'en
l'état il ya vraiment encore des choses
à faire et bien ça ne sera pas parfait
parce que ce qui va être de la zone
d'ombré restera de la zone dont parce
que c'est de la faute aux telle qu'elle
est normalement donc sony n'a pas fait
le choix d'implémenter des algorithmes
qui vont venir tout embellir et tout
éclaircir c'est à vous de faire le taf
puisqu'ici c'est un smartphone qui
destinait +1 10 créateurs des créatifs
et à des photos ça c'est extrêmement
important il faut vraiment bien le
savoir parce que si vous voulez un
smartphone claque une belle photo et
c'est tout est géré automatiquement non
ici on vient d'en gratouiller ci et ça
et c'est ce qui explique également tous
ces paramètres qui sont un peu bizarres
cinéma pro vidéo pro musique trop on le
voit on s'adresse aux créatifs dont bon
moi ce que j'aime bien ici c'est la
dalle même si je lui reproche de ne pas
avoir tout rafraîchissement 100 verte
adaptatif aujourd'hui c'est un peu quand
même une aberration sera smartphone
comme ça l'expérience multimédia malgré
tout est quand même plutôt pas mal une
très bonne expérience de visionnage une
superbe expérience audio est un
smartphone qui est puissant qui
permettra de faire tourner tous les jeux
que vous voulez très facilement lire
chauffer un peu ça c'est à cause du
snapdragon 8 james wan bon plus grosse
batterie est meilleure autonomie dans
l'ensemble bien si vous aimez ce format
là si vous aimez sony et si vous êtes
créatif et que vous aimez venir gratter
dans votre smartphone dites moi vous ce
que vous en pensez ce que vous avez déjà
eu un smartphone de sony il ya très
longtemps ou récemment si ces récents
est ce que vous aimez leur façon de
faire est ce que vous comprenez leur
façon de faire est est ce que vous vous
y retrouvez et est ce que vous pourriez
vous y retrouver une fois de plus dans
ce smartphone dit le moment comment être
là parce que c'est vraiment intéressant
j'ai eu l'occasion de parler avec sony
alors il ya le podcast à ce sujet là qui
est pas si vieux on comprend un peu
leurs façons de faire on comprend où ils
veulent aller on comprend leur
fonctionnement dont je vous invite à
venir l'écouter si vous êtes curé voulez
savoir comment ça se passe réellement
dans la tête de sony dites moi ce que
vous en pensez vous en bas dans les
commentaires et puis nous on se retrouve
très rapidement bel évidemment pour
continuer à parler de teck et ça c'est
une excellente nouvelle voilà je vous
embrasse connaissez-vous début du chaos
[Musique]